Pat forty covers college football for
Yahoo Sports and he was busy he's been
busy so he had to go he lives in
Louisville so he had to go all the way
to Cincinnati for UCLA Cincinnati and
then he had to go all the way to
Louisville to watch last night's game
with Notre Dame in Louisville you've got
to be exhausted Pat thank you for
joining us grind never stops dan I know
you know I know gotta keep going all
right so what do we we start negative or
positive today let's start negative
that's more fun okay I guess I would
start there at least from last night I
was very underwhelmed by Notre Dame I
think Notre Dame was under wealth by
dotard a talking to them afterwards
you know he in book knew that he played
poorly Brian Kelly said that basically
our veterans got to take it up another
level I think they were complacent I
think they came in Thicket or play off
their little review we're in control
here and then started that way and then
Louisville showed a little bit of spunk
in Notre Dame didn't respond all that
well and yeah they won and they want my
18 points but I think everybody there
knows in three weeks they got to play
Georgia and if they play like that
against Georgia they lose by 18 what
else stood out because there were a
couple of embarrassing losses any loss
worse than Tennessee's no the only thing
more embarrassing than what Tennessee
did was what you freezed it but that's a
whole other matter really now Tennessee
was just that was incredible for them to
lose Jamie Georgia State 2 and 10 last
year pick to finish last in their
division of the Sun Belt which means
basically you're running to be the worst
FBS team in America and they go in and
not just beat them if they handle them
especially in the second half they push
them around they had 24 points 240 yards
after halftime Tennessee looked like
they quit defensively I thought and
that's that's a really bad sign at home
in your season opener against the bad
gene yeah you know you have a couple of
those losses Missouri losing to Wyoming
Florida State losing at home
Mountain WestEd will weaken they've had
foreign power five victories and several
open come back double did you come back
fashioned so you know good to have Boise
back back on the radar with the turn
freshman quarterback and Nevada wins on
a kicked by a true freshman on a 56 yard
field goal who was a walk-on he got a
scholarship after the game I was nice
nice weekend for the little s that's for
sure
I'm curious about Oklahoma if we look at
Lincoln Riley and and are we not giving
him enough credit for this offensive
system that he has there you bring in
hurts who I don't know if people looked
at as a pro quarterback but he put up
incredible numbers I know it's week one
but you you know you had Kyler Murray
who comes in you had Baker Mayfield who
comes in and now Jalen Hertz transfers
in is it the system here was a lot of it
I mean I think daddy's gotta look at
Lincoln Reilly and say nobody's doing
better work with quarterbacks in the
country right now than what he's done
and yeah Jay I mean John Hurt's has had
done a lot I mean at 7,500 yards total
offense Alabama over 70 touchdown so
he's I mean he was a player but you're
right I don't think anybody considered
him that kind of a quarterback from a
passing standpoint I mean he ran well
too but but for him to throw like that
first game with a new surrounding cast I
was dazzled maybe Houston's terrible but
I got to give credit that you know I
think Lincoln rally to probably put a
pop-up toaster at quarterback and if 400
yards of offense out of them JT Daniels
out for the season with the torn ACL and
his backup transferred as his backup
coming back to USC it's interesting clay
Helton said the door is always open to
him and when he said that he's going to
transfer he said it's the team keeps
being I'm available so you know it's
kind of one of those half break up
breakups but I you know everything they
said so far this week is that there
with teeth and slovis a true freshman
you know not a super high-level recruits
you know they're playing Stanford this
week here's the problem for USC Dan it's
just the early schedule is really hard
you lose your starting quarterback week
one and you're in behind the eight ball
because you're not you're not playing a
bunch of cupcakes early so if this is
crunch time right now for clay health in
terms of keeping this job biggest
matchups this next weekend
which one would a.m. Clemson
I don't know Michigan Army is that
interesting oh yeah I mean I would say
the biggest ones LSU Texas you know
that's a that's a great international
game the kind of games on campus that
you'd see more of and then we're going
to see eventually SEC vs big 12 to
schools that you know they're trying to
break through and reach the playoff and
the winner of that game is going to feel
like they're gonna have a chance to do
that you know i i've fascinated LSU
really actually did look like they've
gotten an offense together now they were
playing Georgia Southern we'll see what
happens in history sense but if they if
they can finally throw the ball with
some verbs they could be a real
challenge to to Alabama but that yeah
yeah I am
Clemson also big game and yeah I would
say watch out for arming and what
they're gonna bring to the Michigan
problematic style of play to get ready
for good team and you know say if they
just inhale the ball for 3540 minutes of
the game it's gonna be a close game if
you had to cast a Heisman vote today
how about prediction guaranteed to have
us play it back at the end of the year
and make fun of you Travis egn at
Clemson you know the brand like crazy
Thursday night in their first game and
Trevor Lawrence is going to be great and
gonna put up numbers all year but I
think they they can be run first and
just to have Travis ETN be the
centerpiece of the offense and then
they've got you know four or five guys
different guys to throw to
I mean they're just gonna they're gonna
now points are going to rack up yards
and they're gonna win constantly you
know the next couple weeks really are
going to be their only challenges in
terms of opponents and after that I
think they're super seasoned so I would
say whoever turns out to be Clemson's
most productive offensive player yeah is
your Heisman favorite yeah I just wonder
if they're gonna be passing in the
second half just like with tool with
Alabama that they're these guys can't
build up the numbers that other players
can because their teams are so good and
it feels like Clemson is gonna be
running the football
Alabama be running the football I don't
know how much you put Lawrence out there
in the second half or the fourth quarter
and the same with twoa so sure you know
yeah and it's not these come you know
Nick Saban and dabble Sweeney's job to
get these kids a Heisman it's it's their
job to win national championships and
get you know keep them healthy and
healthy so I I don't think Nick Saban is
gonna go let's put two or back out there
so I can bring some big numbers there I
don't think they will and that was very
like last year
and he didn't throw a fourth-quarter
pass for most of the season you know
what until the latter stage is when he
actually was playing in the fourth
border and yeah that'll probably be the
same thing for Trevor Lawrence and
that's you know yeah a week a tackle
after he threw an interception and memos
guarantee was like let's not do that
he's gonna keep him as much out of
harm's way as possible I think this year
so yeah I would imagine that the best
players for Clemson and Alabama are
these three quarters or even a half
again Pat thanks for joining us safe
travels this next weekend we appreciate
your time as always my pleasure Dan
thank you happy football to you that's
Pat 40 Yahoo Sports national columnist
covers college basketball college
football for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]